[Musik]
wenn damit sagen auch wir herzlich
willkommen und starten direkt mit einer
breaking news aus dem
ministerpräsidenten gespräch das wir
gerade bei angela merkel hören ja nele
wir hören in diesem moment dass die
kanzlerin den persönlichen fehler
eingesteht für die oster ruhe das
bedeutet die oster ruhe soll gestoppt
werden übernimmt die volle persönliche
verantwortung für den fehler der in
anführungszeichen oster ruhe das
bedeutet die oster ruhe also das oster
einsperren sowie es noch gestern nacht
oder vorgestern nacht beschlossen wurde
ist es bestätigt die oster ruhe ist
definitiv vom tisch das was so
kritisiert worden ist ist jetzt wieder
eingefangen worden in dieser neu
angesetzten mpk in dieser video schalte
der kanzlerin mit den
ministerpräsidenten gehören in diesem
moment aus der runde
die oster ruhe ist gestoppt und ein
zitat der kanzlerin
sie übernimmt die persönlichen die
persönliche verantwortung
dass das ganze ein fehler war das ist
eine hammer nachricht muss man sagen das
hat es noch nicht gegeben das ist einmal
noch mal dazu sagen die oster ruhe das
waren jetzt gründonnerstag und
karsamstag die jetzt genau in diesem
jahr einmal zusätzliche ruhetage
dazugezählt werden sollte man sollte
also einen hammer lockdown über die
feiertage dann habe und genau das findet
jetzt also doch nicht statt nicht mal 48
stunden eigentlich nachdem es
beschlossen worden ist genau wir
erinnern uns alle an diese nacht sitzung
zurück was war da passiert es gab ein
streit um urlaub im eigenen land um
urlaub in deutschland daniel günther
manuela schwesig und andere wollten das
durchsetzen darauf hin hat die kanzlerin
die sitzung unterbrechen lassen
ursprünglich waren 15 minuten angesetzt
und dann hat man sich über 56 stunden
dort zusammengesetzt in einer
viererrunde unter anderem olaf scholz
war mit eingeschaltet markus söder
der bayerische ministerpräsident und der
berliner bürgermeister und dort hat die
kanzlerin gesagt dass das alles nicht
ausreicht sehr klar gemacht sie will
entweder die ausgangs beschränkung oder
und das passierte dann plötzlich die
sogenannte oster ruhe die auf den tisch
kam nach bild-informationen wir haben ja
heute darüber berichtet wurde das ganze
im kanzleramt bereits am wochenende
entwickelt als mögliche option so und
dann hat man verhandelt und am ende
haben die aaa länder das ganze mit
gemacht und man hat dass das muss man
auch sagen auf der pressekonferenz dann
um 32 3 uhr nachts mitten in der nacht
verkündet hat gesagt das ist jetzt unser
entschluss aber dann ist chaos
entstanden weil in dieser mpk hat unter
anderem der innenstaatssekretär von
seehofer horst seehofer war offenbar
schon ins bett gegangen um diese uhrzeit
hat der gesagt ich kenne diesen
vorschlag seit 15 minuten erst und das
ist schwierig wie wie das rechtlich
umzusetzen das kann er nicht einschätzen
dann heute morgen in corona im kabinett
im normalen kabinett hat man gesagt dass
es logistische probleme geben könnte
wenn man gründonnerstag dicht macht also
mit den lieferungen zum beispiel für
wurst und käse waren die logistiker sind
ihn aufs dach gestiegen es gab überall
probleme und vor allem gab es eine
riesen wut heute in den zeitungen
gestern in den kommentaren insgesamt gab
es eigentlich kaum jemanden der das
gelobt hat niemanden in den medien die
gesagt haben dass seine gute idee
gewesen und da hat die kanzlerin jetzt
reagiert dass sie so klar ein fehler
eingesteht die verantwortung selbst
übernimmt das gab es in dieser krise
bisher noch nie
du sagst in die medien und damit
natürlich auch in der bevölkerung ein
ganz ganz großes thema genießen viele
offene fragen bei den menschen müssen
sie arbeiten gehen wer zahlt ist dafür
jetzt sehen wir also die konsequenz
daraus um 9 uhr 53 heute morgen gab es
die einladung zu diesem erneuten gipfel
zwischen angela merkel und den 16
länderchefs also alles sehr sehr
kurzfristig eine gute stunde nur jetzt
sind sie sich zugeschaltet und gleich am
anfang diese nachricht angela merkel
übernimmt die persönliche verantwortung
für den fehler der usa
dieser beschluss damit also jetzt keine
48 stunden später schon wieder gekippt
von angela merkel selber